a president Trump leveled the design of
the proposed border wall on Twitter take
a look at that but will this important
project ever be funded joining us now
freedom caucus chairman congressman mark
meadows Ohio Congressman Jim Jordan good
to see you both congressman Jordan
what's the answer to that question will
it ever be funded yes remember Greg just
last week in the Oval Office Nancy
Pelosi told the President of the United
States there aren't the votes in the
house to pass a bill with funding for a
border security wall
just last night 217 Republicans proved
her wrong and voted to pass a bill with
dollars for a border security wall this
makes good sense the only reason we're
going to be headed to a shutdown here in
a few hours is because Democrats don't
want to support something that will
actually secure the border plain and
simple congressman meadows you know
Trump promised it he has tried to
deliver the house delivered but the
Senate won't so is this the Chuck
Schumer shutdown well in indeed in just
a few hours when it shuts down the only
person standing between really getting a
deal and not getting a deal is Chuck
Schumer but I can tell you you mentioned
you know Peter Doocy was talking about
the vice president it's his entire team
that has been working on Capitol Hill
all day the vice president Mick Mulvaney
shahira night Jared Kushner the
president has been on the phone with
senators and congressmen throughout the
night his desire is to not shut it down
but it's also to deliver to the American
people a secure border and we've got to
do that he's made a promise he's
committed to that I believe we'll get it
done but right now there's not a deal
primarily because the Chuck Schumer
Chuck Schumer and a device that was
conjured up as a Senate rule called the
filibuster congressman Jordan you know
this is exactly what the framers didn't
want they argued about having it and
they abandoned the idea because they
tried it before the Articles of
Confederation and it led to chaos and
dysfunction you know over the last
decade hundreds of productive bills have
been defeated by this artificial device
called a thorough bus
isn't it time to end the filibuster for
everything once and for all
yeah I think that's where that's where
I'm at that's where the American people
are but that's not our call it's a
sentence call but you're right Greg it's
not in the Constitution it is a Senate
rule imagine if they kept the filibuster
for Supreme Court nominees Neil orach
and Brett Kavanaugh wouldn't be on the
Supreme Court so they were able to
change the rule for something that
important it seems to me when you're
talking about our nation's security when
you're talking about building a border
security wall which was the fundamental
promise we all made the voters in 2016
and certainly the promise that the
president made and wants to deliver on
seems to me this is a paramount
importance where we should actually say
United States Senate maybe you need to
change that so we can get this done
we're gonna keep pushing we're gonna get
the wall done the president's committed
to it as Mark said and they their team
his team has been working hard tonight
trying to get members to understand how
critical this is and actually deliver
for deliver for our country so
congressman monado's your critics would
say well wait a minute
Republicans have had control of the
House and the Senate for two years and
the White House for the better part of
two years and yet you have failed to
undertake comprehensive immigration
reform that would include a border wall
so doesn't the GOP leadership meaning
McConnell and Paul Ryan and others bear
the lion's share of the blame well
there's certainly enough blame to go
around and putting something on the
President's desk is what Congress should
have done I will say this though Greg is
the president actually made a four
pillar option and it was Chuck Schumer
who said no to that option I mean he's
been more than reasonable great think
about this we spend more money on sugar
subsidies than we do on building a wall
on to secure our nation I find that just
incomprehensible I mean and so as we
look at this the president has made
offer after offer after offer and has
been very reasonable it is time that we
put something on his desk I know Jim
Jordan and I are committed but more
importantly the mirror of the American
people are committed to doing it you
know jason Chaffetz your former
colleague in front
and ten day column today on foxnews.com
and he said wait a minute isn't there
another way we have a four point four
trillion dollar annual budget one
trillion of which is discretionary
Congress doesn't authorize every penny
surely the president can grab five
billion of that and use it without
specific authorization to start
construction well he knows but here's
here's the interesting thing and sorry
Jim to jump in here go ahead he can but
I know all your viewers know that he
gets sued over everything in the minute
that he does that he's going to get sued
they're gonna get some liberal judge in
California to say that it won't work and
and so listen we would would certainly
support some of those unobligated funds
going that way but it's really incumbent
on Congress to do their job
that's why Jim and I are still here in
DC we're committed to getting
congressman Jordans so you've got four
days really because you know government
workers aren't going to work Saturday
Sunday Monday they have the Hollett the
day off
of course the holiday unto it so you've
got four days what can be done well we
got to just keep pushing and making the
argument mark is exactly right we need
to appropriate dollars so this doesn't
get tied up in court and we never get
the wall and one point six billion is
not going to cut it it's got to be more
money than that so we can actually get
this done for the American people the
big thing I think we have to get through
is Democrats have to be less focused on
stopping the president and more focused
on helping the country they're so
concerned about stopping President Trump
from accomplishing things let's just
focus on what's good for the country
everyone knows will have a less less of
a drug problem less gang violence less
human trafficking problem if we secure
the border and build the border security
wall we just got to keep making that
case keep pushing because we know when
it comes down to it the American people
are with us this is why they put Donald
Trump in the White House we have to
deliver and I think that message will
get through it we're going to get
something
Congressman Jim Jordan mark Meadows two
important members of Congress thank you
for taking the time to speak with us